everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're gonna be looking at
game 11 from the 2014 World Chess
Championships magnus carlsen is up a
game he's actually playing the white
pieces today there's only potentially 12
games in this series of Magnus Carlsen
in some way pull a victory out he will
be our champion Vichy and on gets to
play the 12th game with the white pieces
so he's looking for at least a draw here
but if potentially he could have the
upset with the black pieces for the win
he could actually go into tomorrow with
the white pieces trying for the victory
so we'll go ahead and get started Magnus
Carlsen starting with white pieces as
we've seen before pawn to e4 and fishing
on up and to this point he's combated
this with two different ways one is the
Berlin defense after pawn to e5 and the
others been the Sicilian offense pawn to
c5 he opts for the Birdland offense pawn
to e5 and the Knight f3 knight c6 the
right Lopez and then Knight f6 the
Berlin defense again this is what they
played all through outs and just two
games ago in game number nine they
played possibly the fastest game I've
ever seen in World Championship it was
about 20 moves it lasted about an hour
total they just kind of blazed through
it and for the beginning part of this
game they did the exact same thing so
they didn't waste a lot of time both
sides you could tell had some novelty in
their head that they wanted to play and
it was just kind of waiting back and
forth to see who was actually gonna make
a variation from game number 9 so we see
Castle Knight taking here on e4 pawn up
to d4 again these are all moves that
we've seen all throughout the
tournaments at Bishop taking here pawn
taking here on c6 and then exchanging
the knight coming back here to f5 I was
a little disappointed to be honest with
vicia not giving up his queen so early
on I know he's done in the past it just
hasn't done much for him he's always
done well in this tournament so far when
he had his queen actively putting a lot
of pressure on his opponent so to go
down this line maybe he has some crazy
plan but I was a little disappointed to
see him give up that clean early on King
taking here on d8 upon 2 H 3 and then we
see our first novelty and it comes from
vision on so you can tell that he's
maybe prepared something
magnus carlsen may not be ready for he
plays Bishop here to these seven
different than the King to Yeates line
which we've seen in the past and usually
when you see Bishop to d7 and you don't
try to centralize your King to e8 it's
usually you're gonna be rushing your
King over here to the b7 squared which
is a critical Square in the Berlin
defense so he's kind of going for that
option magnus carlsen is going to just
continue to develop his pieces he has a
pretty good board state right now he has
the only central pawn he has a safe king
over here he can easily deploy all of
his pieces and get them very involved
into the action so right now pretty
interesting to see how this enon attacks
this but magnus carlsen definitely has a
good game going so far we now see Knight
to c3 just developing move pawn here to
h6 keeping this Bishop off of a g5 also
the night here on g5 can be pretty
troublesome Magnus Carlsen plays pawn
here to b3 he had a few options of where
he could have played he could have
brought his bishop to f4 if he wanted to
he just could have brought his rook over
here to e1 get it behind your pawn so
you can add more pressure to the central
squares
I decided first to go ahead and play
pawn here to b3 getting ready to think
it was Bishop here to b2 and try to
control this long dark diagonal here
King over here to see ace we talked
about trying to get to the square here
on b7 and then he wants to be able to
connect his rooks he definitely needs to
make sure he gets his dark squared
Bishop involved into the game if it just
sits back here on f8 that's not gonna be
good for vision on Bishop here to be two
as we said before pawn here to c5
getting ready to push forward with pawn
here to b6 kind of control are the all
those dark diagonal squares for pawns on
the Queen side rook over here to a d1
centralizing attacking this Bishop right
here pawn here to a b6 this King is
protecting this bishop for now but the
bishop will definitely want to move so
that the King can come here to b7 a rook
over here to e1 and I really like this
setup but what kind of look what both
sides are looking to do white has
complete control of the center he has
both of his briefs connected he's
completed his development he's Castle
although you know with the Queen's off
the board he doesn't have to worry
too much about King safety but all of
his minor pieces are very involved into
the action they're controlling the
center White has the only central pawn
right here for a vision on he hasn't
moved his dark square bishop he hasn't
moved either of his rooks they're
definitely not connected his light
square bishop right now it's gonna be
difficult for him to really use it
effectively and he has to worry about
this central pawn so he's going to be
looking to kind of open up the game get
his dark square Bishop involved maybe
counter-attack with these rooks it may
be in the center of the board it's not
clear how he would attack on either the
queen or the King side there's just not
a lot of options right now so that's
what both sides are kind of be looking
to do as we get into the later stages of
the middle game but I would definitely
give the nod right now to Magnus Carlsen
playing a very fundamentally sound game
Bishan brings his Bishop to e6
centralizing just kind of stopping this
pawn pushing forward and also making
sure that his King doesn't have to
protect the square on d7 a Knight to d5
and this is interesting because if you
look from blacks perspectives a lot of
times you'll actually see the knight
come up here to e7 first because they
just don't want to have to deal with the
knight coming here to d5 but a vision on
actually welcomed it he played this
Bishop here to e6 pretty confidently a
pawn here to g5 so starting to
counter-attack on the Kings side of the
board
pawn here to c4 just solidifying the
center of the board right here Magnus
Carlsen now has a great outpost here on
the d5 file or the d5 square he also if
he wanted to he could use these squares
appears to the d6 or the f6 square he
could always play you know Knight to d2
up to e4 and then here to f6 that would
be a great outpost for his Knights on
the other hand a busy Don could bring
his Knights eventually if he wanted to
Knight to e7 and they could always bring
it to g6 and then he has his own outpost
here on f4 if you wanted to take
advantage of that so there could be for
awhile so I'm just maneuvering back and
forth as both sides don't have a lot
because it's kind of gridlock in the
center of the board so they can just
incrementally get a better position with
their Knights that could definitely be
a changing point in the game this she
finally brings his king to b7 which he
wanted to do now his a rook here is open
to go ahead and get involved into the
game King over here to h2 kind of an
important move if he ever wants to push
forward with pawn to g4 then he's only
one move away to play King to g3 to
protect that a little bit more than he
has right now pawn to a5 so vis she's
starting to counter-attack on the Queen
side pawn to a4 just doesn't want to
have to deal with that attack right now
Knight up here to e7 s we talked about
opening up the door if he wants to
exchange here that could be one thing he
could also bring it over here to g6 and
then f4 which I think could be his best
play pawn to a g4 just stopping all of
the potential threats that vision on
might be thinking of Knight over here to
g6 which is definitely gonna be good
King up here to g3 so more of a central
square which is always going to be good
machine on decides to go ahead and get
his dark square Bishop involved into the
game he plays Bishop here to e7 I
personally don't like this at all I
think if you're going to get your darks
for a bishop moment of the game to go
ahead and just play Bishop here to g7 it
still controls this pawn it controls
this long diagonal and I just think all
around it's just better but both of
these do open up the door for the rook
to get involved so after Bishop here to
e7 he does have his rooks connected he
has completed development so that's
definitely good night over here to d2
rook up here to a d8 a knight up here to
e force we talked about getting ready to
come to the square here on f6 this she
brings his bishop back here to f8 which
kind of had me scratching my head that
he brought his Bishop here to e7 and
then just brought it back here to f8 I
think he just been better if he had it
here on g7 Knight up here to f6 oh great
outpost for Magnus Carlsen for both of
his knights here is night here on d5 and
f6 are controlling a lot of vichy anons
board he has a very cramped position
that there's just not a lot that he can
actually do in this board state he plays
pawn here to b5 another move I just
don't like from Vichy and on
I think you could have tried for
something inmate more he could have
played pawn here to c6 forcing this
Knight to move so this Knights maybe he
comes back here to III I guess it could
come back here to c3 maybe doesn't want
to block off his doctoral Bishop so
night to e3 and then Knight here to f4
nice outpost for this for vision ins
Knight right here so that's gonna be
very good decided again in the game to
go ahead and play pawn here to b5 I just
don't think it's nearly as good bishop
up here to c3 just waiting to figure out
how he wants to defend all this pawn
taking here on a4 we see the pawn
recapture and then the King up here to
c6 trying to control this central square
here on d5 this is definitely a critical
square that both sides are going to be
focusing on so Magnus Carlsen starts to
do the same thing he plays King to f3
starting to come up the board as well
rook over here to b8 trying to control
some of the Queen side so it definitely
has some options over there King up here
to e4 and so both sides very central
kind of gridlock right now so it's kind
of anyone's game as far as who's gonna
take the first move here and actually
try to go for a win or they could just
exchange all the material off go for a
draw and then go into game number 12 and
vision on decided to go ahead and bite
first and decided hey I may not have a
chance in the next game to actually get
a victory so I'm gonna go for it here
and he plays rook to be for now he did
have kind of a safer option he does
control kind of the Queen side
definitely this B file he could have
played rook here to b3 safer move he
still has a lot of attacking options but
decided for the most aggressive line he
could go for and that is rook to b4
basically giving up material for in a
passed pawn here so he could start to
push forward so that's definitely his
plan right now is to just make sure that
he has damage control over here and then
pushed forward for the win with his pawn
here on b4 so Magnus Carlsen is gonna
bring his knight over here to h5 we now
see the King come back here to b7 pawn
up here to f4 so Magnus Carlsen
tried to kind of deflect some of the
attention over here on the kingside he
moved knight over here to h5 also
protecting this square here on f4 so we
do see the exchange right here now after
the Knight takes and that comes back
here on f4 machine on though didn't have
to take with his knight he could have
again
he always has this in-between move of
pawn here to c6 he was playing somewhat
fast though I think he made a lot of
mistakes maybe missed a few
miscalculations that kind of led to an
advantage for Magnus Carlsen but decided
to go ahead and exchange off the
material right here and then the bishop
comes down on c4 so definitely opening
up the door for him to start pushing
forward over here or rook up here to d7
very aggressive move from Magnus Carlsen
you always want your rooks not only on
open files but to control your
opponent's 7th rank if your whites or
the second rank if your black we now see
rook here to a6 it's just not a hundred
percent clear how fishing on as he's
sacrificing material and exchanging
materia off the board how he's gonna
have nearly enough material to protect
this pawn as it comes down here but
Knight to d5 centralizing this Knight
very very nice move from magnus carlsen
this night and this rook are both
attacking the square here on c7 so the
route comes up here to c6 again fishing
on even though he kind of had that
exchange they're still kind of in
defense mode right here and then we see
the rook over here to f7 so getting some
of that material back Bishop to c5
centralizing a little bit and the Magnus
Carlsen plays what I think so far is the
best move in the game the best move that
he's played for a while since the past
few games they haven't been doing
anything too crazy at all but he plays
rook to c7 taking that pawn after the
exchange right here he takes with his
Knights and vision on can't really take
with his king you know if he takes here
on c7 then all of a sudden rook over
here to c1 he's gonna lose one of these
bishops and then he just doesn't have
the material bishop verse Luke in the
in-game with white having more pawns
that's definitely gonna be bad so
fishing on recognizes that this was just
a great move by Magnus Carlsen decides
to go ahead and play King to c6
needs to hold on to his double bishop
pair Knight to b5 another great move by
magnus carlsen somewhat forced his
vision arla doesn't have to take it but
he definitely gets into trouble if he
just allows magnus carlsen to kind of
hang out here
so decides to go ahead and take and then
decides he's gonna go ahead and push
forward on the Queen side and that's
kind of the last thing magnus carlsen he
has his own past pawn so he's going to
be pushing for the win up here with six
pawn here to ab3 king over here to d3
just trying to stop any attack that
vichy and on has a bishop here to e7
needs to make sure that this pond does
not push forward any further it does
have protection from this rook even if
magnus carlsen you know gave up this
pawn
he'd definitely just take this bishop
and it would be game over from here it's
not it doesn't do too much if this pawn
comes down here to be too because after
King to c3 or C - you know this pawn is
just going to fall so that's gonna be
bad decides to go ahead and play Bishop
here to e7 pawn up here to h4 and this
is a really good move as well it's it
kind of goes under appreciated sometimes
of these small little moves that magnus
carlsen does but he recognizes that this
bishop can't just take with or he just
can't take this pawn right here on h4
because then this pawn could just march
up the board even if he hangs his rook
here on e1 the pawns just gonna come up
the board right now after pawn here - a4
he continues with pawn here to g5
another great move he recognizes that
his opponent at some point would like to
play Bishop to f6 to kind of control
this long diagonal right here pushing up
this pawn here - a one maybe the
Shannons best option right here so after
the pawn takes the pawns now I'm gonna
recapture here on g5 and this pretty
much stops vision on being able to help
these pawns over here again Magnus
Carlsen would be completely fine if you
took here on g5 but that really doesn't
do much good for vichy and on now the
pawn to a3 King over here to c3 and
vision on this situation is forced to
resign the madness Crossing can easily
just push these ponds up and there's no
way for him to protect his pawns over
here so managed Carlsen
the game this chignon kind of wind just
all in but I just think he didn't really
calculate all the way through and just
made a few miscalculations I don't think
in this particular game he played all
that great and general Magnus Carlsen
however played fantastically so he is
the 2014 world chess champion and he
will be the champion for two more years
when we come back in 2016
for the next chance for someone to
dethrone him so there will not be a game
12 so for those fans that just like
seeing matches unfortunately the
tournament is over but congratulations
to Magnus Carlsen back-to-back
championships two years in a row he is
dominating he also won the rapid and the
blitz earlier this year so he is just
crushing chest right now excited to see
him as he gets better and better thank
you guys for watching the coverage and
the entire series hopefully y'all are
learning something and definitely
enjoyed watching him and I'll see you
guys in the next tournament thanks for
watching